it has become one of the most infamous
dates in modern history
[Music]
the terror attacks on 911 took the lives
of nearly 3 000 people and it changed
the world
on the morning of september the 11th
2001 two planes flew into the world
trade center in new york we believe that
a plane has crashed into the world trade
center hijacked american airlines flight
11 and united airlines flight 175
crashed into the north and south towers
killing at least 2
750 people
it just blew up a big explosion people
started running it was just chaos
everywhere i saw the plane hit the
building
i can't say anything people are jumping
out the windows over there jumping out
the windows i guess because
they're trying to save themselves
that same day another american airlines
flight crashed into the pentagon just
outside washington dc
killing 187 people
a fourth airliner united 93 was also
hijacked and was believed to be heading
for washington dc too the target the
capitol building but it crashed into a
field in pennsylvania after the
passengers and crew tried to regain
control
the terror group al-qaeda led by osama
bin laden was quickly identified as
being responsible for the attacks
in total nearly 3 000 people died the
worst terror attack on u.s soil in
history
america was consumed by grief anger and
revenge
i can hear you the rest of the world
hears you
and the
people and the people who knock these
buildings down
will hear all of us soon
[Applause]
the response by the west led by america
under the presidency of george w bush
marked the start of the so-called war on
terror
freedom itself was attacked this morning
by a faceless coward and freedom will be
defended within just weeks of 9 11 the
us bombing of afghanistan began
afghanistan was run by the taliban who
allowed al-qaeda to grow and operate
within the country
when the taliban refused to hand over
bin laden the u.s supported by nato
forces began a war to oust them and take
down al qaeda
they went in with a very narrow tactical
objective to root out
um the terrorist leadership that they
realized that they couldn't sustain that
situation without an investment in
nation-building the nation-building part
of the exercise
ultimately was bought it would become
america's longest war
tens of thousands of afghans have been
killed and many thousand american and
nato troops too in all the united
nations estimates that nearly quarter of
a million people have died most of them
civilian
and it all came to an end for america in
2021 when president joe biden pulled us
troops out of the country afghanistan
swiftly fell back to the taliban once
again
terrorists grow and thrive in security
and governance
vacuum so the way that we've left
afghanistan
doesn't bode well
the war in afghanistan was followed two
years later by the invasion of iraq on
the elusive hunt for saddam hussein's
weapons of mass destruction
there began another long war for america
no weapons of mass destruction were
found saddam hussein was toppled and
sectarian tensions in the country were
stoked all with profound regional
implications
in 2020 a study estimated the war on
terror has led to hundreds of thousands
of deaths and around 38 million war
refugees and displaced people
on may the 2nd 2011 nearly 10 years
after 9 11 u.s special forces shot and
killed a man in hiding in a house in
northwestern pakistan a decade after 9
11 they'd got him
after a firefight they killed osama bin
laden and took custody of his body the
war on terror was also waged at home
with the introduction of the patriot act
it allowed the u.s government to keep
tabs on its citizens tapping phone calls
emails and more there hasn't been a
major islamist attack in the u.s since
2001 and that's essentially been the u.s
measure of success
but if you look at this from a global
perspective you've seen a massive
attacks from bataclan to christchurch
all of which in a way linked back to
this
not not to speak of the continuing and
rising terrorism across africa and
the middle east as the u.s war on terror
continued the spotlight shined back on
america's own behavior it emerged that
the cia was secretly taking suspects to
countries on so-called rendition flights
where they could torture them the
guantanamo bay detention center became a
symbol of america's failure to uphold
the values it seeks to defend
20 years after 9 11 40 prisoners remain
at guantanamo most have not been charged
none have yet faced trial they include
the 911 mastermind khalid sheikh
muhammad
of course 911 had other impacts as well
it led to an increase in anti-muslim
sentiment across america and beyond
in 2017 a survey found that half of u.s
muslims find it more difficult to live
in the country since the attacks
islamophobia and anti-muslim bigotry
predates the tragic events surrounding 9
11 but they were certainly in
uh an exasperation in normalization of
that bigotry
in the immediate aftermath i think that
when we
we reflect on the last two decades
with respect to the american muslim
community it's important to note that
that experience has largely been a mixed
bag on the one hand we've seen increased
integration of muslim americans in
almost all spheres of law
politics and society you know on a
different note however we've also seen
increased
discrimination against muslim americans
[Music]
one other impact of 911 has been air
travel it has been transformed to make
us safer but with huge implications
before the attacks security wasn't as
intense and check-in cues were nowhere
near as long that has now all changed
there are also changes on the planes
themselves of pilots now locked beyond
heavily reinforced cockpit doors
9 11 has become one of these symbolic
moments for america an inflection point
in the country's history it was and it
remains a moment of deep trauma the
long-lasting effects of 911 of the war
on terror i think you know are
very visible in many ways i mean
afghanistan
again of course we we're still facing
the consequences of iraq which led to
isis isis is not gone all of which
you know also prevented a response to
syria
um and the aftermath of syria in a way
totally reshaped europe reshaped
attitudes emboldened a new far right
deepened polarization around this new
global fault line and in a way if i were
to say the tragic um
outcome of 9 11 is that it succeeded in
doing what it wanted to
and that is
to polarize us
in new ways